por que é tão difícil falar sobre
dinheiro
queria saber de vocês quantas vezes por
dia
vocês falam o pensam em dinheiro mais
duas mais de dez tinha uma que fala
assim o dia inteiro só penso nisso então
dinheiro é uma coisa que faz parte da
nossa vida né a gente compra coisas vêm
de coisas pensa se tem muito dinheiro
pouco dinheiro se vai faltar se vai
sobrar se eu vou mudar de emprego não
vou mudar de emprego
se eu tenho como pagar o hospital será
né em a vida da gente o dia inteiro a
gente tem essa
esse item na nossa vida quem é que acha
que ganha bem
nossa
quem é que acha que gasta pouco
um pouquinho mais mas há pouco que é que
acha que sabe investir bem o dinheiro
que tem o que só se sobrar menos ainda
então eu suponho que o inverso é que não
levantou a mão
acha que ganha pouco gasta muito e não
sabe investidas à serra
cada fase da vida da gente carrega uma
realidade diferente ou seja tem fase que
eu até acho que estou ganhando pouco e o
que me falta mesmo é ganhar mais outras
fases eu acho que eu estou gastando
muito e o que eu preciso gastar menos
outras fases e sobra um pouco eu acho
que eu não sei investir coisa nenhuma
porque esse mundo fala grego e eu não
consigo entender como é que eu faço para
investir então eu acabo deixando uma
coisa chamada poupança mesmo qualquer
coisa do gênero
na verdade eu durante essa minha vida de
de empresas quando conversava com as
mulheres uma coisa que eu percebi era
assim as mulheres queriam muito seguir
em frente e fazer carreira subir mudar
de emprego mudar de vida mas tinha
sempre uma coisa meio angustiante que
era eu não tenho o suficiente e todas as
vezes que elas venham conversar ela
ao conversar com um desses três itens na
mão
ganhando pouco estou gastando muito anos
e investiu eu quero migrar e não estou
nem pensando em dinheiro o que eu vou
dizer pra vocês não é nada de de
brilhante né não precisava ter estudar
tudo que isto deva saber isso
mas a vida é composta dessas três coisas
em conjunto
não adianta ganhar bem se eu gastar mais
do que eu ganho
não adianta ganhar bem e gastar menos
mas não saber faça o que eu faço com a
diferença
não adianta eu ganhar pouco se eu gasto
mais do que eu ganho ou menos mais um em
visto então se a gente tem que lembrar
alguma coisa para poder cuidar da nossa
vida e da nossa vida financeira a gente
tem que pensar nessas três letrinhas que
eu chamo de gee
quer dizer é sempre uma composição entre
quanto eu ganho mas quanto eu gasto mas
como é que eu invisto diferença quando
vocês levantaram a mão normalmente as
pessoas pensam isso penso que estou
ganhando pouco o que eu estou gastando
muito e eu sempre um exemplo que quem
ganha 10 e gasta 7 é mais rico do que
quem ganha 100 e gastar 110 matemática
pura dá certo
é fácil falar às vezes é difícil de
fazer porque a gente tem muitas questões
como é que eu ganho mais como eu faço
para pedir aumento como é que eu faço
pra aumentar preço como é que eu faço
para ter mais clientes
então cada uma desses itens tem questões
individuais mas é só a composição dos
três que vai dar pra gente uma saúde
financeira
por que é tão difícil falar sobre
dinheiro
a grande maioria das pessoas com quem eu
converso tempo e eu tô falando do
público feminino em especial tem grande
dificuldade de falar sobre dinheiro
não se fala em casa a frase que eu mais
ouço é assim tudo mas depois de
conversar sobre isso eu fico pensando
que a gente devia ter tido aula disso no
pré-primário né
ouvi falar disso na minha casa porque
não se fala disso porque é chato porque
é feio porque é ruim é normalmente as
pessoas não falam de dinheiro até que
alguma coisa aconteça e essas alguma
coisas normalmente estão dentro dessas
duas características
dessas duas categorias o eu começo a
pensar que a minha vida não vai dar
certo ea conta não está fechando e eu
não estou conseguindo sair deste meu
lupi deste dilema então tem alguma coisa
de errado e eu preciso de ajuda
o eu sinto que quem está em volta de mim
tá é com um problema então eu até sou
bem sucedida ou até todo dando conta
mas meus pais meus irmãos meus amigos
quem está próximo
está com problema nessa hora surge a
vontade de conversar sobre este tema
nem sempre a gente consegue audiência
para conversar quando as pessoas são
solteiras ou dependentes dos pais ela
tem vontade de conversar com os pais e
os pais na maioria das vezes não fluem
nessas conversas com essa são difíceis e
os pais não fluem essas conversas porque
eles têm as questões dele certo tem
muitas muitas pesquisas que mostram que
90% dos pais não dividem com seus filhos
e com a sua família em informações
relevantes
então eu até encontro mulheres bem
educadas de boas famílias com boa saúde
inteligentes bonitas mas que estão com
questões muito importantes na vida
afetiva na vida do trabalho e na sua
própria independência porque né e às
vezes o fundo disso é uma dificuldade de
entender com julgar o que está
acontecendo na sua família e os pais às
vezes têm os seus contextos eles não
querem conversar porque tem coisas que
eles acham que não são conversar weiss
quero começar com os meus filhos sobre
dinheiro porque eu não quero debater que
eu tenho filhos do outro casamento mas
mulher dívidas problemas na empresa
tem coisas que acontecem que os impede
de entrar nessa conversa
existem também crenças as crenças que eu
mais vejo acontecer em são os pais que
dizem assim mas eu fiz tudo sozinho eu
fiz o que eu tinha para fazer
se for ajudar muito os meus filhos eles
vão ficar preguiçosos aumentar a rede e
não vão querer fazer o quê
o que eu suponho que eles deveriam fazer
se eu conseguir ele também consegue né
muitos pais quando vêm as suas filhas
dizem eles duas vezes é um com suas
baias né é um é uma coisa inconsciente
mas mulher não devia mesmo está se
preocupando com isso
é eu acho que essa conversa não é uma
conversa adequada então juntando os
contextos com as crenças do porque não
se conversa isso em casa essas conversas
ficam muito bloqueadas
setenta por cento dos casais isso também
são pesquisas feitas por universidades
americanas é da cornell university
brigam por causa de dinheiro em brigas
feias e bravas porque eles vêm de
contextos diferentes então eles entendem
que a maneira de se viver
são diferentes entre eles e quando não
tem conversa
então se a gente sai de uma família que
não conversa a dificuldade de se
conversar com o parceiro com o marido
com a mulher também se carrega
normalmente existem também várias
pesquisas que demonstram que casais que
são dependentes um do outro por dinheiro
tem um nível alto de infidelidade
eu li uma pesquisa ultimamente que diz
que os homens que ganham menos do que as
suas mulheres
astrada em média cinco vezes mais do que
os homens que ganham mais do que sua
mulher e esse número
esse número é bacana porque assim menor
traição de casal acontece quando a
mulher ganha 75 por cento do homem não 0
não 10 mas 75% ou seja ganha ganha o que
é e mas não mais do que imagina quanta
conversa tá e as mulheres que ganham
mais do que os homens traem média metade
do que uma mulher que que não que não
ganha mais que o homem isso do lado da
mulher então você vê que tem distinções
importantes sócio-culturais e de baias
que a gente tem que conversar
é na realidade uma realidade cada
família uma família
os temas de amor e dinheiro porque o
dinheiro não é nada dinheiro é só uma
energia né dinheiro carrega junto com
ele uma porção de coisas ele em si é um
papel que o tesouro nacional
imprimir na casa do tesouro imprimir ea
só um papel mas o que ele carrega ele
carrega uma porção de de emoções de
sentimentos de energias de dúvidas de
questões de sobrevivência ou não
sobrevivência de poder não é bem essa
pesquisa bacana que eu gosto da maneira
que ele demonstra que esqueça lingerie
massagens e champanhe e vai conversar
sobre dinheiro com seu marido que se o
que mais ativa vida a boa vida sexual no
maracanã
só isso já devia ser um incentivo para a
gente fazer é conversar sobre o tema e
que temas têm para serem conversadas nos
casais quer dizer como é que eu faço
para trabalhar quanto eu vou trabalhar
quando você vai trabalhar quanto cada um
de nós vai colaborar aqui que a gente
faz 44 com a divisão não tem regra tenha
necessidade de trazer este tema à tona
para poder se chegar às a aos acordos
pessoais né
então eu digo que as conversas salvam
vidas porque as conversas tinham as
pessoas de um lugar de angústia às vezes
de depressão de falta de amor de falta
de entendimento porque a gente começa a
criar na cabeça da gente uma porção de
teorias que olha que você vai conversar
às vezes não é nada daquilo que você tá
pensando que é o que está acontecendo eo
maturana costuma dizer que no mundo tudo
se modifica a partir daquilo que eu
desejo conservar
então se o desejar conservar uma boa
relação em volta de mim e através de um
diálogo amoroso a gente vai conseguir
fazer com que nisso que eu quero
conservar tudo em volta vai se acertando
queria contar pra vocês
alguns grupos que eu participe poder
conversar sobre dinheiro
nós temos grupos de mulheres que falam
sobre dinheiro que a gente chama de
inteligência financeira tem uma
plataforma junto com o itaú chamado tal
mulher empreendedora a gente faz
mentoria para poder ajudar as conversas
com as empreendedoras
fiz um grupo de criação de mulheres pra
conselho mulheres do mundo empresarial
para se formarem para serem conselheiros
de administração tem um outro que eu
adoro que são as meninas de 13 anos a
gente trabalha com uma ong mogi das
cruzes onde a gente descobriu por um
trabalho na índia de que a gente salvar
as meninas de 13 anos de ficarem
grávidas elas têm a possibilidade de ter
um ciclo virtuoso na vida dela eu compro
material escolar junto com amigas a
gente é que o material escolar novinho
lindo maravilhoso igual àqueles que dava
para os meus filhos ea gente trata de 40
meninas por ano de 13 anos com uma
equipe multidisciplinar nessa ong para
poder fazer conversas de como é que elas
não vão ficar em grávidas não adianta
tratar de 1516 porque às vezes esse
ciclo já passou
e tem esse grupo que eu amo de paixão
que são meus filhos junto com um grupo
de amigos que eu comecei a fazer pedido
deles quando ele estava no colegial e
eles diziam tinha posso ir na sua casa
falar sobre anos sei direito o que eu
vou fazer de faculdade eu não sei
direito se eu vou trabalhar em cima
daquilo não sei é depois eu dou na
faculdade eu não sei como é que eu faço
para me preparar para fazer um serviu
para fazer uma entrevista eu quero
discutir os temas é tendentes do mundo
quero então a gente se reúne e isso
começou na mesa da minha sala de jantar
com os amigos dos amigos dos amigos que
vão pedindo pra vir e eu separei um dia
na semana que era sextas feiras à tarde
onde recebia todo mundo lá em casa quem
quisesse vir para a gente poder debater
o que eu quero dizer com vocês é que pra
conversar para poder passar o que a
gente sabe para os jovens as meninas
para as mais velhas das mais novas a
precisa só saber conversar
não precisa nem ser conversador
profissional então eu convido vocês
estilo vocês a criarem os seus grupos de
conversação conversarem com seus pais
conversarem com seus filhos abrirem
essas de argos entenderem o que está
incomodando o que está bloqueando o que
é possível para a gente poder fazer um
próximo passo porque se a gente ajuda a
abrir o diálogo com aqueles que estão
próximos
o diálogo a nível maior no mundo ele
também vai acontecendo
muito obrigada